get your uh workspaces all you know in
order here folks because we are going
top of the flow chart right here
wrestlemania coming up right here on
peacock this very weekend we are
thrilled to have here on the rich eisen
show wwe superstar wwe raw women's
champion
and um and one of the all-time greats in
the history of wrestling on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is becky
lynch how are you becky
i'm great how are you doing i'm doing
fine so um are you ready to kick some
ass and take names oh hell yeah right
hell yeah i am i stay ready to kick
someone okay
um so um we all know whose ass you're
going to attempt to kick uh but bianca
bel-air is uh pretty stout in her own
right so what do you what can you tell
us to expect coming up this weekend
becky i attempt to attempt to kick her
ass i i don't appreciate that i don't
appreciate attempt i will i will i've
already beaten her in 26 seconds that's
embarrassing that's embarrassing rich
i've already beaten her in 26 seconds i
demolished her two weeks ago on on raw
when i took her out or maybe three weeks
ago now almost when i took out her
throat after she hit me as hard as she
could with a cheap shot a cheap shot it
was after the match and she hit me as
hard as she could with a cheap shot and
put me in the hospital so i have to do
the same for her there's going to be no
attempting it will be a matter of fact
i'm going to beat her and if she thought
26 seconds was was bad she thought that
was embarrassing just wait until
wrestlemania so uh is this the point
where i apologize for how i set up the
question you can apologize to me you can
apologize to me okay uh uh becky lynch i
apologize to you and everything that you
stand for and all of your fans and the
legion of fans who support you um i
apologize
is that good all is forgiven
man i feel like i just took one in the
throat but okay very good
you don't want the manhood i know that i
know that so um
so the the the
let's go in this direction then um how's
motherhood treating you how's being a
parent right how's that going oh man
it's the best it is the best she's she's
the perfect little freaking angel
well she's a perfect combination of
angel and psychopath you know you you
want like a little bit of a weirdo baby
another
random weird stuff and so she's she's an
entertainer i mean considering who her
parents are it just shouldn't be
but
okay sorry my throat's still a little
bit scratchy from bianca and that cheap
shot and but she's she's great the only
the only problem not the best sleeper
but
but we bring her everywhere and so um
and so if that's the only trouble she
really gives us
i can deal with that i'll just drink
some more coffee okay so while you take
that uh sip then my uh my question for
you is what is the becky lynch seth
rollins tag team parenting um skill set
can you walk me through what that looks
like thank you
i think i think it's pretty it worked
out pretty well um uh
excuse me throat still a bit and
i will uh i tend to be the one that
opened her in in the middle of the night
you know um i'm still nursing her and so
in the morning then he'll take her
look after her so i can catch up on a
few z's if i need them and uh and and
then whenever it comes to anything i've
got experiences he'll look after
and he's got appearances i'll look after
it's pretty great thank you um let's uh
let's let's get into um you know your
your world in in wrestlemania right now
i mean so
uh you you have definitely uh ascended
to a certain spot what if i told you
when you first got started that this is
the way wrestlemania in 2022 would be
going for you
becky lynch gosh it's one of the it's
one of those things right where you set
off and
you have these dreams and you have these
ambitions and you have these goals but
i'm somebody who failed pe at 15 years
old so so i never i never i never
thought that i could
be where i am today of course i wanted
it but but you're i feel like when
you're going after a dream you're
constantly
battling maybe um
doubt
and uh
there's this weird over compensation of
confidence that comes up sometimes so
it's this weird um it's this weird
battle and this weird struggle but but i
think if you told me that everything
that's happened in the last
two three half of the last 10 years um
even being in wwe i don't know that i
would have made it here because i think
my head would have exploded yeah i don't
blame you so how difficult was pe in
ireland that you reflected
honest to god i don't think it was that
hard i think it was just because i
refused to do anything i thought it
looked stupid running i still look
stupid running but at least they do it
now you know and so um
and so and so um at the time you know i
whenever whenever i was asked to do
anything i would just stand there you
know do you remember that cartoon daria
and you and and and she would play
whatever it was soccer or something okay
you know she just stand there and put
her hand out i feel like i've got a
visual image of of me being exactly like
gary i was in gym class okay and uh
and that's
your failing grade that's your failing
grade yeah yeah yeah that was my feeling
great that was my failing grade i was i
wasn't created much else english and
history i was okay
awful
well i think it's all worked out you
know i realized at age 15 i couldn't do
anything uh with the ball or so i just
decided to talk about it now here i am
today talking to you so i feel like uh
you know some similarity right here
becky lynch on the rich eyes worth it
you know it worked out well for both of
us i think honestly the ability to talk
has helped me immensely too i love it um
tj you want to ask a question tj
jefferson our social media grand maester
who is also our wrestling aficionado
you're going to wrestlemania this
weekend i will be in the building you
will be in the building so okay go for
it
ask becky what's your what's on your
mind becky what's going on how are you
doing today
i'm good i'm good apart from that
coughing fit i'm great
well i got a question but before that
you brought up the haircut on monday and
i'm sorry to see that happen but becky i
mean you saw the oscars right you know
you can't mess with these queen's hair
sometimes bad things happen so but you
are rocking the haircut very nicely so
hang on
let's bring this back let's bring this
back a second do you remember why i went
for her hair i do remember see bianca
has a braid and uh she she kind of
slapped becky with it and left the mark
so becky was coming for it
no not just left a mark she scarred my
body
yes
potentially possibly probably not but
she did attempt to
and so and so of course i was going to
go after her it's an illegal weapon it
was an illegal weapon that she was using
in the match
the audacity becky lynch the odds the
audacity the audacity and if we look at
history we look at last year's
wrestlemania when bianca won the main
event of wrestlemania against sasha
banks how did she win she hit her with
her braid right before the finish and
then got her into the kod and so like
any same person would i was trying to
cut her hair off to preserve my win at
wrestlemania to take away that weapon i
get it look i understand why you did it
you know i'm just saying though but
becky here's one thing i want to talk to
you about um back in november of 2018
the moment where you know right leaning
up to summerslam you got hit you had the
blood dripping down your face and it
became that moment like i actually went
on twitter that night and i said this uh
becky lynch her face crimson mask got
her moment like we know in wrestling
there are just times when something
happens and you know this person has now
become made this person is now a star
when i saw you standing there blood on
your face arms outstretched crowd going
nuts i knew that that moment was it for
you like you were
top of the food chain
looking back at it can you remember
anything i know you got a concussion but
do you really remember
what happened at that moment and while
you were up there in the crowd like you
know soaking in the adulation was that a
conscious thought in your mind or was
you were you just trying to get through
the moment
i
i was honestly if i if i answer honestly
i would say i would love nothing but
honesty becky between us
i was going through the through through
the motions and i was i was i was
knocked out on my feet perfectly and so
when i came back through the curtain i
was just like where am i but looking
luckily enough my subconscious took over
and my subconscious also happens to be a
badass so that's nice and handy
yeah it's like i said it was just one of
those moments you know you have jimmy
snuck on top of the cage you have hogan
slam and andre you have austin not
tapping out the brett in the
sharpshooter with blood dripping down
his face you standing there bloody like
and we never saw that from a wwe woman
before and i thought that moment was it
and that made made us realize who you
were and so that was just i mean it was
an awful moment but it turned out to be
something great i think right and now we
got wrestlemania coming up on peacock
this very weekend um becky let's do this
again when uh you don't get uh cheap
shot in the throat
um
and and um you know whenever you're in
l.a i'd love to have you here in person
we'd love to meet you
absolutely i would love to come on i
actually um
live half the time in l.a so we should
definitely make that happen fantastic
when we the rich eisen show also offers
babysitting services so oh really
very handy it might actually go out on a
date or something where where can you
look after everyone we're a full service
program we love the kids we love the
kids we do we do we absolutely do
we absolutely do uh thanks for the call
uh becky good luck to you this weekend
look forward to seeing how it all plays
out with your um immediate victory um
without a doubt
awesome thank you thank you so much see
you this weekend i'll be there yelling i
just learned my lesson with uh becky
lynch right here
on the rich eisen show on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line right
there
showcase of immortals on the grandest
stage of them all do not miss the most
stupendous
two night wrestlemania in history
second and third saturday and sunday
right here on peacock and for those
listening who may not have peacock
what is your mouth function
i'm sorry that is not on this uh
that was aggressive that's my new yorker
and me coming in that's how you feel
rich i'm sorry well you were inspired by
becky to cut a promo oh yes
you have one of the best promos ever i'm
sorry i should i should just uh mention
you go to peacocktv.com to sign up
that's what it says here and it's not as
aggressive and it's actually informative
and actually gets people to sign up i
like the way you did it first to be
honest with you sometimes you got to
like you know okay
scare people that's the way i promote
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here